We're in the middle of an ongoing war
we love to have the big guys join the fight
Welcome back everyone Transformers rise of
the Beasts was just released hopefully you've had
a chance to see it I got a lot of questions about
the post-credit scenes there are two of them in
the big crossover they're teasing so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos and
careful for spoilers if you have not seen rise
of the Beasts yet since we're talking about the
ending of the movie but during the ending Optimus
Prime Optimus primal with the help of the Beast
Wars Transformers the maximals stop Unicron from
using the transwarp key to travel to the Milky Way
galaxy Earth galaxy they never say which part of
the universe Unicron was coming from because of
all the Easter eggs and references during the
movie we know that it wasn't near Cybertron
because during the movie both Optimus Prime and
Optimus primal references saying that they don't
want you to cron to get the key not only because
he can use it to travel anywhere in time and space
giving him a theoretically infinite worlds to feed
on but Unicron could also use it to find Cybertron
and try to consume it here's the thing though
Cybertron is literally the body of unicron's twin
Primus who's meant to be just as powerful as
Unicron I'll explain how Primus became Cybertron
later in the video just because it's a whole
big thing because the whole idea is that Unicron
versus Primus would be like the Transformers
version of Avengers end game it would be like the
last big thing that they do you're talking about
two god-level Transformers going to war with each
other two planet-sized Transformers battling it
out there are a couple points in the movie where
Scourge and the terracons referenced Primus even
though the Transformers themselves like Optimus
Prime doesn't reference Primus himself but I do
think they're working up to more Primus stuff I
think that's what they're mentioning him in
the movie like oh yeah we're gonna do Primus
eventually too but once they destroy the key
unicrons trapped in the other Galaxy Anthony
Ramos's character Noah Diaz interviews for a
new job which is a random business he doesn't
know exactly what he's interviewing for he just
thinks it's for a regular job he enters a common
import export business travels down the stairs
to a meeting room where he meets an agent Burke
who isn't from the original Transformers or GI
Joe Cannon he's meant to be like a totally new
character unless he was using some alias in the
scene like he could wind up being somebody from
the GI Joe Cannon but he starts interviewing
Noah for the job joking about the gaps quote
unquote in his resume like when they start talking
about his recent job time in Peru Burke lets him
know that he's been monitoring what he and the
other Transformers were doing there and he knows
everything like he and the people that he works
with the GI Joe characters know all about Optimus
Prime all the Transformers Unicron the maximals
the transwarp key everything he says he works for
a covert government agency that would like all
of them Noah and his large Transformer friends
to work with them because of an ongoing war that
they're in the middle of they start panning around
the room as Noah starts getting confused and
anxious you start noticing GI Joe Easter eggs on
the wall all these plaques all these signs there's
even a plaque that reads Real American Hero which
is the GI Joe slogan which Burke then shifts
activating a door revealing an underground Hangar
Bay with a bunch of advanced technology ships and
weapons he hand him a card to contact him when he
decides when he says yes in the GI Joe symbol is
on the back so they're basically saying the next
Transformers movie sequel will be a Transformers
GI Joe crossover and they're connecting the Hasbro
Cinematic Universe if you haven't been following
Transformers and GI Joe for a while you probably
heard talk of them doing a crossover for a long
time like this toy Cinematic Universe they did a
version of this in the Marvel Universe with Secret
Wars back in the 80s it was their way of doing
like a giant Avengers end game level movie before
they were doing those giant Marvel movies like
they needed a reason to sell toys so they wanted
to do this giant event and that became Secret Wars
but it was mostly for the purposes of selling
all these toys they did the same thing in the
Star Wars Universe in the 90s with shadows of the
Empire because it was before the prequels had come
out so if you've been following the GI Joe movies
the Transformer movies for a long time or you just
been fans of the toys the TV shows for years and
years and years there's been talk about them doing
this crossover for a long time but the reason
why the producers said that they didn't do it but
for this is because they couldn't figure out
how to do it logically without it just feeling
like a total cash grab this is the producer
of that next Transformers in GI Joe crossover
movie talking about it you know we've talked
about it for a long time and the fans have been
you know really rabid about it which is great
you know and so it makes you want to do it we
we never found a really organic way to do it and
I think one of the things is you just don't want
to do it in a way that feels I'll say cynical you
know that that you're just jamming in it because
there's more fans and the fans are going to like
it you know so what happened was Anthony's story
the story of Noah is a character who is having
a hard time because of Life getting a job and it
and it just felt like so organic that what job is
he going to finally break through with GI Joe the
way I would look at it and I think the way we
understand it is the maximals we barely touch
the surface so we really got to bring them into
the story in a way into the continuation of the
story and then we'll introduce some Joe characters
so it'll be kind of a group if you would uh what
mission they're going to go on we don't know what
what's what's the task who are we saving it from
we don't know so we're not going to add a host of
maximals or a host of GI Joe's or hosted Autobots
we've got to try to keep the group somewhat tight
do we bring a new Duke in do we bring a new you
know uh it's hard to think about exactly some of
the ones we've done although they absolutely could
exist in this world so Snake Eyes is probably
my favorite Joe so maybe Snake Eyes will fit
very organically here so during his little talk
there he seems pretty clear when he's setting
up what's happening in that GI Joe's Transformers
crossover movie it's more of a Transformers movie
focusing on more of the maximals with some of the
key Transformers like Optimus Prime and Bumblebee
in a couple of the GI Joe characters a couple of
the big GI Joe characters so it's not that they're
going to ram in like every single GI Joe character
ever and it's not going to be more of a GI Joe
movie with Transformers in it it'll feel more like
a Transformers movie with GI Joe characters folded
into it he does seem pretty certain that snake
eyes and probably Duke are going to be in that
movie so I think that confirms my theory about
them rebooting part of the timeline for the GI
Joe movies the whole war that they were talking
about the GI Joe was meant to be in the middle
of fighting and needed the Transformer's help for
was against Cobra obviously because we're talking
about GI Joe here like I mean who's GI Joe gonna
fight a war against but Cobra there aren't any
huge Cobra references that I could see in that
post-credit scene but if you spotted any or any
in the wall or any in their dialogue just write
them Below in the comments they haven't done any
GI Joe live action movies set earlier in the
timeline around the 80s and the 90s when they
started doing the Bumblebee movie reboot and
now this movie which is set in the 90s but the
whole idea with the Bumblebee reboot was reboot
shooting the Transformers timeline so they could
change whatever they wanted to like bumblebee was
meant to be a soft reboot even though there seems
like there are loose connections with the Michael
Bay Transformers I think the idea with them doing
this Transformers GI Joe crossover sequel next is
that they will do the same thing for the GI Joe
movie timeline they'll reboot that like they had
the Snake Eyes movie recently but it did terribly
like it bombed big time and I think they're just
ready to move on with something totally different
and this is the opportunity to do that so because
they've never done GI Joe movies set earlier in
the timeline they can reintroduce or introduce
versions of the characters earlier in the timeline
and it won't break anything just because it will
be a reboot so like Duke Cobra Commander all the
other characters anybody they want to introduce
they can do earlier now really good example of
that is like John Cena's character in bumblebee
even though he's not meant to be Duke they could
just say that he's playing a version of duke or
he's playing another totally different character
that just winds up going to work for GI Joe at
some point after the Bumblebee movie speaking of
the Bumblebee movie they were also going to
include Haley steinfeld's Charlie character
from that movie during rise of the Beasts early on
the plans fell through at some point even hailee
Steinfeld was confused about that she's like
yeah why am I not in this Transformers rise of
the Beasts movie they did say that Charlie would
come back in the movies eventually and they're
probably saving some of the Bumblebee story for
that too because Mirage for example was a much
bigger character during this than bumblebee was
and usually you would expect bumblebee to get a
lot of that story but the whole idea here with the
timeline is that they have till about 2006 when
that first Michael Bay Transformers movie came out
to play with so 10 years worth of timeline to plan
what I'm expecting though in that a couple years
they'll announce when they're going to release
this Transformers GI Joe movie and it'll probably
still be set during the 90s I don't think they
want to jump the timeline forward too much like
a little time Jump after this movie which was in
1994 so maybe the crossover movie is in 1995 or
1996. then in the next post-credits scene there's
another time Jump after the interview with the GI
Joe characters Noah's in another garage with reek
who's been helping him assemble the parts to
build a new version of mirage's body which was
a Porsche 964 Carrera RS 3.8 I don't think you
could actually buy those in the United States
during the 90s I think you actually could only
get those in Europe he also uses the parts that
Mirage gave him to create his Transformer suit
like Mirage had transferred his Essence into
the suit even though they were kind of coy about
that like wait a minute is he still alive inside
the suit or something like that but the idea is
that he wasn't destroyed in the final fight just
parts of his body once the car is finished being
assembled Mirage reveals that he's been alive this
whole time and what the car begins to transform
but it's a bit of a bumblebee situation where he
looks all beat up because the car parts were all
from second hand different color Porsches but it
just means Mirage will be back in that next
Transformers in GI Joe crossover movie just
to explain the whole Unicron versus Primus thing
though like that's something that's probably way
further off in the Transformer sequels Unicron and
his twin brother Primus are sort of like the twin
gods of the Transformer Multiverse you Unicron
is more of like a dark god of the Transformers
and Primus is like the light side God creator of
all Transformers that includes all factions of
the Transformers like all the autobots as well as
the Decepticons the Predacons the maximals every
different version of Transformers that evolved
over time so then doing Unicron is sort of them
going back to the origin of the Transformers
Multiverse they actually just announced that
they're actually doing a movie about the origin
of the Autobots and the Decepticons called
Transformers 1 with Chris Hemsworth of all people
playing young Optimus Prime they'll also probably
use some of that movie to explain the origin of
Cybertron as well as the origin of Primus and his
brother Unicron so I think the idea is that when
they decide to do their Avengers end game level
type of event like the big big movie that will
bring Unicron back and he will fight a version
of Primus Cybertron think of all the toys they'll
sell during that movie alright Peach everyone's
wallets a lot of big stuff coming up in the
next week too all my flash videos there's a
bunch of stuff I'm working on for that movie so
those will be posting soon in my Marvel secret
Invasion episodes we'll be starting soon click
here for that full opening scene from Secret
Invasion Episode 1 and click here for my new Flash
Superman trailer video with Henry Cavill Superman
thank you so much for watching everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one foreign